[Musique]
professeur stéphanie cacioppo de
l'université de chicago
avec mon équipe nous travaillons sur une
pilule contre la solitude donc la
solitude c'est un signal biologique
exactement comme la la soif et la faim
qui nous indique que nous sommes en
manque de quelque chose dans le cas de
la solitude c'est un signal que nous
devons nous reconnecter aux autres pour
survivre en tant que espèce social que
nous sommes mais il ya un paradoxe dans
la solitude c'est à dire que le solitude
n'est pas exactement comme la dépression
quand on se sent déprimé
on se sent triste mais quand on se sent
seul
en ce sens nous seulement triste mais
également en danger des autres la
personne qui se sent seul
on va se sentir un plus attentive à des
dangers potentiels des critiques des
jugements négatifs et 20 pour être
interprété tous les messages ambigus qui
vient d autres comme les expressions
faciales comme des messages négatifs
c'est comme si elle avait un signal
d'alarmé à la maison qui est tout le
temps en marche le système d'armes va
pas faire la différence entre des amis
ou des d un projet où des gens qui
veulent du mal la pilule en fait elle
servirait à réduire l'intensité de ce
système d'alarmé donc la personne qui se
sentent seules aient le courage d'ouvrir
la porte et de faire face aux gens qui
viennent me rendre visite et vraiment
voir les gens comme elles sont soutenir
amis friends et empathique plutôt que
comme des potentiels un ennemi la
première étape la première phase de test
de cette pilule s'adresse aux gens qui
sont extrêmement seul et qui ont été
seuls depuis plusieurs semaines et
plusieurs mois
la pilule a aussi des effets
secondaire que nous devons en comprendre
avant de l'utiliser sur une population
assez l'âge si vous êtes en alerte sans
arrêt vous n'allez pas être ouvert aux
réceptifs aux maux du psychiatre donc la
pilule ce serait pour aider en fait les
psychiatres à ouvrir les portes de
l'inconscient de cette personne et à
réduire les mécanismes de défense de
sept personnes qui ont été en alerte
depuis plusieurs semaines ou plusieurs
mois
est-ce que la pilule est nécessaire
c'est pas parce que il ya un phénomène
biologique qui al'air d'expliquer un
symptôme ou une difficulté que la
solution doit nécessairement être un
médicament
la psychothérapie aussi changent la
chimie du cerveau sans aucun médicament
la même chose pour des interventions
dans l'environnement donc le médicament
pourrait être utile mais je pense pas
qu'il soit nécessaire